Il y a quelques temps, j'ai fait une expérience
Pendant un an, j'allais dire oui à tout ce qui me faisait peur.
Tout ce qui me rendait nerveuse, tout ce qui me sortait de mon confort,
Je me suis forcée à dire oui.
Est-ce que je veux parler en public ?
Non, mais oui.
Est-ce que je veux passer à la télé en direct ?
Est-ce que je veux m'essayer à être actrice ?
Non, non, non, mais oui, oui, oui.
Et il s'est produit un truc incroyable :
le simple fait de faire ce qui m'effrayait
a effacé la peur,
l'a rendue non-effrayante.
Ma peur de parler en public, ma phobie sociale... pouf... disparues.
C'est incroyable, le pouvoir d'un seul mot.
« Oui » a changé ma vie.
« Oui » m'a changée.
Mais il y a eu un oui particulier
qui a affecté ma vie de la manière la plus profonde,
dans un sens que je n'avais jamais imaginé,
et ça commencé avec une question de ma plus petite.
J'ai ces trois filles magnifiques, Harper, Beckett et Emerson,
Emerson est une petite fille qui appelle tout le monde « chérie»
comme si elle était une serveuse du Sud des Etats-Unis.
(Rires)
« Chérie, je vais avoir besoin de lait pour mon biberon. »
La serveuse du Sud m'a demandé de jouer avec elle un soir
alors que j'allais quelque part, et j'ai dit, « oui. »
Et ce oui était le début d'une nouvelle manière de vivre pour ma famille.
J'ai fait le voeu qu'à partir de cet instant,
chaque fois qu'un de mes enfants me demandera de jouer,
peu importe ce que je fais ou où je vais,
je dirai oui, à chaque fois.
Presque. Je ne suis pas parfaite mais j'essaie ardemment.
Et ça a un effet magique sur moi,
sur mes enfants, sur notre famille.
Mais ça a aussi eu un effet secondaire sensationnel,
et ça n'a été que récemment que j'en ai compris toute l'étendue,
que j'ai compris que dire oui à jouer avec mes enfants
a probablement sauvé ma carrière.
J'ai ce que la plupart des gens appellerait un job de rêve.
Je suis scénariste. J'imagine.
Mon job, c'est d'inventer des histoires. Un job de rêve.
Non
Je suis un titan.
Un job de rêve.
Je crée ce qui passe à la télé. Je produis des séries télé.
Je crée de la télévision, beaucoup de télévision.
D'une manière ou d'une autre, cette saison de télé,
je suis responsable d'amener au monde environ 70h de programmes.
4 programmes de télévision, 70h de télé --
(Applaudissement)
3 séries en production en même temps, parfois 4.
Chaque série crée des centaines de jobs qui n'existaient pas avant.
Le budget d'un épisode de télévision
peut être n'importe quoi entre 3 et 6 millions de dollars.
Prenons 5 par exemple.
Un nouvel épisode créé tous les 9 jours multiplié par 4 séries,
donc tous les 9 jours, c'est 20 millions de dollars de télé,
4 séries télé, 70h de télé,
3 séries en production à la fois, parfois 4,
16 épisodes produit en même temps :
24 épisodes de "Grey's", 21 épisodes de "Scandal",
15 épisodes de "How to Get Away With Murder",
10 épisodes de "The Catch", soit 70h de télé,
c'est 350 millions de dollars par saison.
Aux Etats-Unis, mes séries télé
passent les unes après les autres le jeudi soir.
A travers le monde, mes séries passent dans 256 pays en 67 langues
pour un public de 30 millions de personnes.
Mon cerveau est mondial,
Et 45h de ces 70h de télé sont des séries que j'ai créées personnellement
et pas seulement que je produis, donc en plus de tout le reste,
je dois trouver le temps, un moment vraiment calme et créatif,
pour rassembler mes fans autour du feu de camp
et leur raconter mes histoires.
4 séries, 70h de télé,
3 séries en production à la fois, parfois 4,
350 millions de dollars, et les feux de camps à travers le monde.
Vous savez qui fait la même chose ?
Personne. Donc comme je disais, je suis un titan.
Un job de rêve
(Applaudissement)
Je ne vous dis pas ça pour vous impressionner.
Je vous dis ça car je sais ce que vous pensez
quand vous entendez le mot « scénariste. »
Je vous dis ça pour que tous les gens qui travaillent si dur,
que vous dirigiez une entreprise ou un pays ou une salle de classe
ou un magasin ou un foyer,
me prennent au sérieux quand je parle de travailler,
pour que vous compreniez que je ne me tourne pas les pouces toute la journée,
pour que vous m'entendiez quand je dis
que je comprends qu'un job de rêve ne consiste pas à rêver.
C'est du travail. Travail, réalité, du sang et de la sueur et pas de larmes.
Je travaille beaucoup, très dur, et j'adore ça.
Quand je travaille dur, je suis à fond dedans,
il n'y a pas d'autre sentiment.
Pour moi, mon travail est de tout le temps construire une nation de toutes pièces.
C'est gérer les effectifs. C'est peindre sur une toile.
C'est atteindre son maximum. C'est courir un marathon.
C'est être Beyoncé.
Et ce sont toutes ces choses à la fois.
J'adore travailler.
C'est créatif et mécanique et éreintant et excitant
et hilarant et inquiétant et aseptisé et maternel
et cruel et judicieux,
et ce qui rend tout ça si génial, c'est le bourdonnement.
Il y a comme un changement dans ma tête quand le travail devient intéressant.
Un bourdonnement se crée dans ma tête, et il grandit et grandit
et ce bourdonnement résonne comme une route ouverte,
et je pourrai y conduire pour toujours.
Beaucoup de gens, quand j'essaie d'expliquer ce bourdonnement,
pensent que je parle de l'écriture de scénario,
qu'écrire me remplit de joie.
Et ne vous méprenez pas, ça me remplit de joie.
Mais le bourdonnement --
Ce n'est que quand j'ai commencé à faire de la télé
que j'ai commencé à travailler et créer et construire et créer et collaborer,
que j'ai découvert ce truc, ce bourdonnement, ce rush.
Le bourdonnement est plus que la simple écriture.
Le bourdonnement, c'est l'action et l'activité. C'est une drogue.
Le bourdonnement, c'est la musique, c'est la lumière et l'air.
Le bourdonnement c'est Dieu qui murmure à mon oreille.
Et quand vous avez un bourdonnement comme ça,
vous ne pouvez faire autrement qu'aspirer à de grandes choses.
Aspirer à de grandes choses à n'importe quel prix.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le bourdonnement.
Ou alors peut-être que c'est ce qu'on appelle un bourreau de travail.
(Rires)
Peut-être qu'on appelle ça du génie.
Peut-être qu'on appelle ça de l'ego.
Peut-être qu'on appelle ça la peur de l'échec.
Je ne sais pas.
Je sais juste que je ne suis pas faite pour l'échec,
je sais juste que j'adore ce bourdonnement.
Je sais juste que je veux vous dire que je suis un titan,
Je sais que je ne veux pas remettre ça en question.
Mais voilà le truc :
plus je réussis, plus j'ai de série télé,
plus j'ai d'épisodes, plus j'élimine d'obstacles,
plus j'ai de travail à faire,
plus j'ai de balles pour jongler,
plus les gens me regardent, plus l'Histoire me regarde,
plus j'augmente les attentes.
Plus je travaille pour réussir,
plus je dois travailler.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai dit à propos de travailler ?
J'adore travailler !
La nation que je construis, le marathon que je cours,
les effectifs, les toiles, son maximum,
le bourdonnement, le bourdonnement.
J'aime ce bourdonnement. J'adore ce bourdonnement.
J'ai besoin de ce bourdonnement. Je suis ce bourdonnement.
Suis-je seulement ce bourdonnement ?
Et alors le bourdonnement s'est arrêté.
Surmenée, éculée, poussée à l'excès, exténuée.
Le bourdonnement s'est arrêté.
Mes trois filles sont habituées au fait
que leur mère est un titan célibataire qui travaille.
Harper dit aux gens :
« Ma mère ne sera pas là, mais vous pouvez demander à ma nounou. »
Et Emerson : « Chérie, je veux aller à ShondaLand. »
Ce sont des enfants de titan.
Ce sont des bébés titans.
Elles avaient 12, 3 et 1 ans quand le bourdonnement s'est arrêté.
Le bourdonnement du moteur s'est éteint.
J'ai arrêté d'aimer travailler. Je n'arrivais pas à rallumer le moteur
Le bourdonnement ne revenez pas.
Mon bourdonnement était cassé.
Je faisais les mêmes choses que j'ai toujours faites,
tout ce même travail de titan,
15h par jour, à travailler même les week-ends,
aucun regret, jamais battue, un titan ne dort jamais,
ne démissionne pas, le coeur plein, une vision claire, peu importe.
Mais il n'y avait pas de bourdonnement.
A l'intérieur de moi, c'était le silence.
4 séries, 70h de télé,
3 séries en production en même temps, parfois 4.
3 séries en production en même temps --
J'étais le parfait titan.
J'étais un titan que vous pouviez présenter à vos parents.
Tout se ressemblait, et je ne m'amusais plus.
Et c'était ma vie.
C'était tout ce que je faisais.
J'étais le bourdonnement et le bourdonnement était moi.
Donc qu'est-ce que vous faites quand ce que vous faites,
le travail que vous aimez, commence à vous laisser un arrière-goût ?
Je sais qu'il y a quelqu'un qui se dit :
« Plains-toi, stupide scénariste titan. »
(Rires)
Mais vous savez, ça arrive,
si vous créez, si vous travaillez, si vous aimez ce que vous faites,
être instituteur, être banquier, être mère, être un peintre,
être Bill Gates,
si vous aimez une autre personne et que ça vous donne le bourdonnement,
si vous connaissez ce bourdonnement,
si vous savez ce que ça fait, si vous avez déjà été ce bourdonnement,
quand le bourdonnement s'arrête, qui êtes-vous ?
Qu'êtes-vous ?
Que suis-je ?
Suis-je encore un titan ?
Si la musique de mon coeur s'arrête, puis-je survivre dans le silence ?
C'est alors que ma petite serveuse du Sud me pose une question.
Je suis presque à la porte, je suis en retard, et elle me dit :
« Maman, tu veux jouer ? »
Et je suis sur le point de dire non, quand je réalise deux choses.
Premièrement, je suis supposée dire oui à tout,
et deuxièmement, ma serveuse du Sud ne m'a pas appelée « Chérie. »
Elle n'appelle plus les gens « Chérie » dorénavant.
Quand est-ce que c'est arrivé ?
Je rate ça à être un titan et à faire le deuil de mon bourdonnement,
et la voilà qui change devant mes yeux.
Et donc elle dit « Maman, tu veux jouer ? »
Et je dis, « oui. »
Il n'y a rien de spécial à propos de ça. On joue,
nous sommes rejoint par ses soeurs, et il y a plein de rire,
et je leur fais une lecture dramatique de « Tout le monde va aux toilettes.»
Rien d'extraordinaire.
(Rires)
Et pourtant, c'est extraordinaire,
car dans ma douleur et ma panique,
sans abri et sans bourdonnement,
je n'ai rien d'autre à faire que d'être attentif.
Je me concentre. Je suis calme.
Le nation que je construis, le marathon que je cours,
les effectifs, les toiles, le maximum n'existent pas.
Tout ce qui existe, ce sont des doigts qui collent
et des bisous gluants et des petites voix et des crayons
et cette chanson sur être libérée et délivrée
de quoique ce soit que cette reine des neiges doit être libérée.
(Rires)
C'est juste paix et simplicité.
L'air est tellement rare dans cet endroit que je peux à peine respirer.
Je peux à peine croire que je respire.
Jouer est l'opposé de travailler.
Et je suis heureuse.
Quelque chose en moi se desserre.
Une porte de mon cerveau s'ouvre,
et un rush d'énergie entre.
Ce n'est pas instantané mais ça se produit.
Je le ressens.
Un bourdonnement revient discrètement.
Pas très fort, à peine là,
il est discret et je dois rester tranquille pour l'entendre,
mais il est là.
Pas le bourdonnement, mais un bourdonnement.
Et maintenant je me sens comme si je connaissais un secret magique.
Enfin, ne nous emportons pas !
C'est juste l'amour. C'est juste ça.
Pas de magie. Pas de secret. Juste de l'amour.
C'est quelque chose que l'on a oublié.
Le bourdonnement, le bourdonnement du travail, le bourdonnement du titan,
c'est juste un remplacement.
Si je vous demande qui je suis,
si je vous dis qui je suis,
si je me décris en terme de séries
et d'heures de télévision et combien mon super cerveau est mondial,
j'ai oublié ce qu'était le vrai bourdonnement.
Le bourdonnement n'est pas le pouvoir, il n'est pas spécifique au travail.
Le bourdonnement est spécifique à la joie.
Le vrai bourdonnement est spécifique à l'amour.
Le bourdonnement est l'électricité provenant d'être enthousiaste à la vie.
Le vrai bourdonnement est confiance et paix.
Le vrai bourdonnement ignore le regard de l'Histoire.
et les balles pour jongler, et les attentes et la pression.
Le vrai bourdonnement est singulier et original.
Le vrai bourdonnement est Dieu qui murmure à mon oreille.
mais peut-être Dieu murmurait les mauvais mots,
car lequel des dieux me disait que j'étais un titan ?
C'est juste l'amour.
Nous pourrions tous utiliser un peu plus d'amour,
beaucoup plus d'amour.
A chaque fois que mon enfant me demandera de jouer,
je dirais oui.
J'en ai fait une vraie règle pour une raison,
pour me donner la permission,
pour me libérer de toute ma culpabilité de bourreau de travail.
C"est une loi, donc je n'ai pas le choix,
Et je n'ai pas le choix,
si je veux ressentir le bourdonnement.
J'aimerai que ce soit si simple.
mais je ne suis pas douée pour jouer.
Je n'aime pas ça.
Je ne suis pas intéressée autant que je suis intéressée pour travailler.
La vérité est plutôt remplie d'humilité et d'humiliation à affronter.
Je n'aime pas jouer.
Je travaille sans arrêt parce que j'aime travailler.
J'aime travailler plus que je n'aime rester à la maison.
L'accepter est incroyablement difficile,
car quel type de personne préfère travailler qu'être à la maison ?
Eh bien, moi.
Je veux dire, soyons honnête, je me surnomme titan.
J'ai des problèmes.
(Rires)
Et un de ces problèmes n'est pas que je suis super relax.
On cours dans le jardin, dans un sens et dans l'autre.
On danse pendant 30 secondes.
On chante des chansons. On joue avec des ballons.
Je fais des bulles et elles les font éclater.
Et je me sens folle de joie et confuse la plupart du temps.
Attraper mon téléphone me démange tout le temps.
Mais c'est ok.
Mes petits humains me montrent comment vivre
et le bourdonnement de l'univers me remplit.
Je joue et je joue jusqu'à ce que je commence à me demander
pourquoi nous avons arrêté de jouer auparavant.
Vous pouvez faire la même chose,
dite oui à chaque fois que votre enfant vous demande de jouer.
Vous pensez que je suis complètement folle ?
Vous avez raison, mais vous pouvez quand même le faire.
Vous avez le temps.
Vous savez pourquoi ?
Parce que vous n'êtes pas Rihanna, vous n'êtes pas un Muppet.
Votre enfant ne pense pas que vous êtes aussi intéressant.
(Rires)
Vous avez juste besoin de 15 minutes
Mes filles de 2 et 4 ans veulent seulement jouer avec moi
pour 15 minutes environ
avant de se dire qu'elles veulent faire quelque chose d'autre.
Ce sont 15 minutes incroyables, mais ce sont seulement 15 minutes.
Si je ne suis pas une coccinelle ou un bonbon,
après 15 minutes, je suis invisible.
(Rires)
Et ma fille de 13 ans,
si j'arrive à la faire parler pendant 15min, je suis le Parent de l'Année !
(Rires)
15 min, c'est tout ce dont vous avez besoin.
Je peux totalement trouver 15min de temps ininterrompu dans mes pires jours.
Ininterrompu, c'est la clé.
Pas de téléphone, pas de lessive, rien.
Vous avez des vies chargées. Vous devez préparer le diner.
Vous devez les forcer à se laver. Mais vous pouvez trouver 15 minutes.
Mes enfants me rendent heureuses, ils sont mon monde,
mais ce n'est pas nécessairement vos enfants,
le carburant de votre bourdonnement,
l'endroit où votre vie est plus heureuse que malheureuse.
Ca ne tourne pas autour du fait de jouer avec vos enfants,
ça tourne autour de la joie ça tourne autour du jeu en général
Donnez-vous ces 15 minutes.
Trouvez ce qui vous rend heureux.
Trouvez ça et jouez dans ce domaine.
Je ne suis pas parfaite. En fait, j'échoue aussi souvent que je réussis,
en voyant des amis, en lisant des livres, en regardant dans le vide.
« Tu veux jouer ? » est devenu une abréviation pour me faire plaisir
d'une manière à laquelle j'avais renoncé
à peu près au moment où j'ai eu ma première série,
au moment où je suis devenue un titan en devenir,
au moment où j'ai commencé à être en concurrence avec moi-même.
15 minutes ? Qu'est-ce qui pourrait arriver de mal
si je m'accordais toute mon attention pour 15 minutes ?
Apparement, rien.
Le fait même de ne pas travailler a permis au bourdonnement de revenir,
comme si le moteur du bourdonnement ne pouvait se ravitailler
que quand je ne suis pas là.
Le travail ne fonctionne pas sans le jeu.
Ça prend un peu de temps, mais après quelques mois,
un jour, les vannes s'ouvrent
et il y a un rush, je me retrouve à mon bureau
remplie d'une mélodie inconnue, en moi et autour de moi,
et ça me donne plein d'idées,
et la route du bourdonnement est ouverte et je peux conduire dessus,
et de nouveau, j'adore travailler.
Mais maintenant, j'aime ce bourdonnement, mais je ne l'adore pas.
Je n'ai pas besoin de ce bourdonnement.
Je ne suis pas ce bourdonnement. Ce bourdonnement n'est pas moi,
plus maintenant.
Je suis des bulles et des doigts gluants et des diners entre amis.
Je suis ce bourdonnement.
Le bourdonnement de la vie.
Le bourdonnement de l'amour.
Le bourdonnement du travail est toujours une part de moi,
il n'est juste plus tout moi,
et j'en suis si reconnaissante.
Je me fiche d'être un titan,
car je n'ai jamais vu un titan faire la ronde.
Je dis oui à moins de travail et plus de jeu,
et curieusement je dirige encore mon monde.
Mon cerveau est toujours mondial. Mes feux de camps sont toujours là.
Plus je joue, plus je suis heureuse, et plus mes enfants sont heureux.
Plus je joue, et plus je me sens une bonne mère.
Plus je joue, et plus mon esprit se libère.
Plus je joue, et mieux je travaille.
Plus je joue, et plus je ressens le bourdonnement,
la nation que je construis, le marathon que je cours,
les effectifs, la toile, le maximum, le bourdonnement,
l'autre bourdonnement, le bourdonnement réel,
le bourdonnement de la vie.
Plus je ressens ce bourdonnement, plus je m'accepte comme
ce tout nouveau non-titan, étrange, frémissant et découverte.
Plus je ressens ce bourdonnement, plus je sais qui je suis.
Je suis une scénariste, j'invente des histoires, j'imagine.
Cette partie de mon travail, c'est vivre le rêve.
C'est le rêve d'un travail.
Car un job de rêve devrait être un peu onirique.
Je dis oui à moins de travail et plus de jeu.
Titan, inutile de présenter votre candidature.
« Tu veux jouer ? »
Merci
(Applaudissement)